This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About five months ago, producer Kim Chaganza opened up a file that was sent to her by her uncle Manu. It was an Excel spreadsheet of Kim's family tree, a project her uncle had been working on for the last several years. So far, there are about 300 names on there, tracing our family's history deep into pre-colonial Zimbabwe, the country where I was born. Ours is a typically large Zimbabwean family. My great-grandfather had two wives and 15 children, and all of them went on to have a minimum of three kids each.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。大约五个月前，制作人金·查加内萨打开了她叔叔马努发给她的一份文件。那是一个关于金的家族谱系的Excel表格，是她叔叔过去几年一直在做的项目。到目前为止，上面大约有300个名字，追溯了我们家族的历史，深入到前殖民时期的津巴布韦，也就是我出生的国家。我们是一个典型的津巴布韦大家庭。我的曾祖父有两个妻子和15个孩子，他们每个人后来至少都有三个孩子。
Soon I'll be adding a new name to the spreadsheet and upping our family's grand tally because I'll be having my first child. So I've been thinking a lot about names. My family tree seemed like a good reference point. My family is predominantly Shona, which is the biggest ethnic group in Zimbabwe. And as I went through it, I was seeing all of the greatest hits,
很快，我就会在表格中增加一个新的名字，增加我们家族的总人数，因为我将迎来我的第一个孩子。所以我一直在思考名字的问题。我的家谱似乎是一个很好的参考点。我的家族主要是绍纳人，这是津巴布韦最大的族群。当我浏览它时，我看到了所有最经典的名字，
the classics when it comes to Shona names. Tapua, which means we've been given. Rwimbo, which translates to faith or trust. And Mnirazi, which means to console. There were also English names, common ones, like Ruth, Gladys, and Lewis. But then Kim started to notice a whole other set of Western names. Actually, to English speakers outside Zimbabwe, they aren't so much names as they are just words.
当谈到绍纳名字时，这些都是经典。Tapua，意思是“我们被给予了”。Rwimbo，翻译过来是“信仰”或“信任”。还有Mnirazi，意思是“安慰”。也有常见的英文名字，比如露丝、格拉迪斯和刘易斯。但随后金开始注意到另一整套西方名字。事实上，对于津巴布韦以外的英语使用者来说，它们与其说是名字，不如说只是单词。
She saw one family member who was named Suffer, another named Medicine. One of her many uncles was named Beer. Outside of the country, these kinds of names are rather unusual. But to me and millions of other Zimbabians, these are fairly standard. What might surprise me is if I were to come across a boy called No Matter, or memory, or privilege, because these are typically regarded as girls' names. I have an uncle called Lovemore, and I have an aunt called Loveness. God knows is quite popular too.
她看到一个家庭成员叫“受苦”（Suffer），另一个叫“药物”（Medicine）。她的许多叔叔中有一个叫“啤酒”（Beer）。在国外，这类名字相当罕见。但对我以及数百万其他津巴布韦人来说，这些是相当标准的。如果我遇到一个叫“没关系”（No Matter）、“记忆”（Memory）或“特权”（Privilege）的男孩，我可能会感到惊讶，因为这些通常被认为是女孩的名字。我有一个叔叔叫“更爱”（Lovemore），我有一个阿姨叫“可爱”（Loveness）。“上帝知道”（God knows）也很受欢迎。
I went to school with any more, talk more, pass more, give more, work more. All of these were in my class. Tanaka Chidora is a Zimbabwean writer, poet and academic. Almost everyone in Zimbabwe is a relative with such a name. Almost everyone. To the extent that when I was growing up and I was called Tanaka, I was wondering, why didn't they also give me a name like Love Mo? You know, because almost everyone around me is such a name.
我和“再多一点”（Any more）、“多说点”（Talk more）、“多通过”（Pass more）、“多给点”（Give more）、“多工作”（Work more）一起上学。所有这些都在我的班里。塔纳卡·奇多拉是一位津巴布韦作家、诗人和学者。在津巴布韦，几乎每个人都有这样的亲戚。几乎每个人。以至于我小时候，当别人叫我塔纳卡时，我会想，为什么他们不也给我起个像“更爱”这样的名字呢？你知道，因为我周围几乎每个人都有这样的名字。
If you were born in Zimbabwe like Tanaka and me, especially in the last few decades, you would have heard these kinds of names all around you. But outside of the country, when people hear us say, Hi, my name is No Rest, Psychology, or Talk More. There are usually questions, comments and jokes. Much of the ribbing is from other Africans, but it also comes from Zimbabians themselves,
如果你像塔纳卡和我一样出生在津巴布韦，尤其是在过去几十年里，你会听到周围都是这类名字。但在国外，当人们听到我们说“嗨，我叫‘没休息’（No Rest）、‘心理学’（Psychology）或‘多说点’（Talk More）”时，通常会有疑问、评论和笑话。大部分嘲讽来自其他非洲人，但也来自津巴布韦人自己，
who, although used to these names, will still raise their occasional eyebrow. My name is Learn More. You know, this is Zimbabwe thing. Like, we have names like this is Zimbabwe. You know, like Learn more, Give More. When I was growing up, my best friend's name was take it easy. Learnmore Janasi is a Zimbabwean stand-up comedian who has gotten a lot of mileage out of his given name.
他们虽然习惯了这些名字，但偶尔还是会挑挑眉。我叫“多学习”（Learn More）。你知道，这就是津巴布韦特色。就像我们有像“这就是津巴布韦”这样的名字。你知道，比如“多学习”、“多给予”。我小时候，我最好的朋友叫“放轻松”（Take it easy）。莱恩摩尔·贾纳西是一位津巴布韦单口喜剧演员，他从自己的名字中获益良多。
Compared to Zimbabwe names like hatred, strongman, or beat them, the name Learnmore might seem mild. But he has not been spared mockery, which he began to discover when he started traveling outside of Zimbabwe. There was this one encounter at the South African border. As soon as the immigration officer took my passport, she was just, like, your name is Learn More? And I was like, yes. She's like, wow. And she called all her other immigration officer.
与津巴布韦像“仇恨”（Hatred）、“强人”（Strongman）或“打败他们”（Beat them）这样的名字相比，名字“多学习”似乎很温和。但他并没有幸免于嘲笑，当他开始去津巴布韦以外的地方旅行时，他开始发现这一点。在南非边境有一次遭遇。移民官一拿到我的护照，她就说，你的名字是“多学习”？我说，是的。她说，哇。然后她叫来了所有其他移民官。
She's like, look, guys, Zabweans are crazy. You know? And just kind of made fun of that a little bit. But I was like, what is that? I've never heard this before, you know? I have friends from all over Africa who look at these names of the mix of amusement and curiosity, but also sometimes ridicule. A guy I once met from Botswana describes Zimbabians as being too
她说，看，伙计们，津巴布韦人疯了。你知道吗？然后就有点取笑这个名字。但我当时想，那是什么？我以前从未听说过这个，你知道吗？我来自非洲各地的朋友看着这些名字，混合着好奇和娱乐，但有时也带有嘲笑。我曾经在博茨瓦纳遇到一个人，他形容津巴布韦人太
whitewashed, pointing to our names as a prime example. Why were we going for these bizarre English names instead of choosing them in Shauna, Devele, Tonga, or any one of our many other indigenous languages? Zimbabwe had such a uniquely dark experience under British colonialism, and it's not easy to square that with us choosing these bold, head-turning English names. Of course, the Shauna aren't the only ones who make single names out of religious expressions, or big sentence-long ideas. People do this all over the world. Linguists even have technical terms for them,
“被洗脑了”（whitewashed），并指出我们的名字就是一个典型的例子。为什么我们要选择这些奇怪的英文名字，而不是用绍纳语、恩德贝莱语、汤加语或我们许多其他本土语言中的任何一种来选择它们呢？津巴布韦在英国殖民统治下有着如此独特而黑暗的经历，要将这一点与我们选择这些大胆、引人注目的英文名字联系起来并不容易。当然，绍纳人并不是唯一用宗教表达或长句思想来起名字的人。世界各地的人们都这样做。语言学家甚至有专门的术语来称呼它们，
like sentential names and theophoric names. But I can't think of anywhere that goes as big and as creative as we do in Zimbabwe. As I read my family tree skimming across names like Polites, Clever, and Admire, I did start to wonder, why do we choose names like this? So common that in other parts of Africa,
比如句子名和神名。但我无法想到有任何地方像我们在津巴布韦那样做得如此宏大和富有创造力。当我阅读我的家谱，扫过像“礼貌”（Polites）、“聪明”（Clever）和“钦佩”（Admire）这样的名字时，我确实开始想，为什么我们选择这样的名字？以至于在非洲其他地区，
people will automatically know that you're Zimbabwean. The reason these names became so quintessentially Zimbabwean goes way back, before there's even a country called Zimbabwe. In our Shona culture, names were meant to communicate. Names were like WhatsApp statuses. Just like people today use their WhatsApp statuses to celebrate, brag, and reflect in front of their communities, Tanaka Chidora says,
人们会自动知道你是津巴布韦人。这些名字之所以变得如此典型的津巴布韦特色，可以追溯到很久以前，甚至在有一个叫津巴布韦的国家之前。在我们的绍纳文化中，名字是为了交流。名字就像WhatsApp状态。就像今天的人们使用他们的WhatsApp状态在社区面前庆祝、吹嘘和反思一样，塔纳卡·奇多拉说，
Shona names traditionally did something. similar. Those names carried the stories of parents' hopes, dreams, and worries. Names were careers of our aspirations, our achievements, our grievances, our tribulations. Just to note that although there are many other ethnic groups in Zimbabwe, I'll be focusing on the Shona. Within the culture, names could also be used to chide, insult, or even settle scores. For example, Tanaka says, a mother who finds her in-laws to be troubled. might name her daughter, Netzai, which means to bother or to nag. A man who has gone through lots of problems could give the name Namu to his son.
绍纳名字传统上也做着类似的事情。这些名字承载着父母的希望、梦想和担忧的故事。名字是我们抱负、成就、不满和苦难的载体。需要注意的是，虽然津巴布韦还有许多其他族群，但我将专注于绍纳人。在文化中，名字也可以用来责备、侮辱甚至算账。例如，塔纳卡说，一位发现婆家很麻烦的母亲可能会给她的女儿起名叫Netzai，意思是“打扰”或“唠叨”。一个经历过很多问题的男人可以给他的儿子起名叫Namu。
Namu means misfortune or hardship. They were meant to communicate to us and to our neighbours, that this is who we are, this is what we have achieved. These are the problems that I'm going through right now. Names could be a plea to ancestral spirits for guidance and protection. They could express future desires and imminent fears. Zimbabwean academic Ignatius Mabasa remembers the saga behind how one of his great uncles got his name. The story goes that one night before his uncle was born, a family member ran off with his neighbor's wife, her husband threatened to get revenge by burning down the entire village.
Namu意味着不幸或苦难。它们旨在向我们和我们的邻居传达：这就是我们，这就是我们所取得的成就。这些是我现在正在经历的问题。名字可以是对祖先灵魂寻求指导和保护的恳求。它们可以表达未来的愿望和迫在眉睫的恐惧。津巴布韦学者伊格内修斯·马巴萨记得他的一位叔祖父是如何得到他的名字的传奇故事。故事是这样的：在他叔叔出生前的一天晚上，一个家庭成员带着邻居的妻子私奔了，她的丈夫威胁要通过烧毁整个村庄来报复。
The same village, Mabasa says, where his uncle's parents lived. So they had to escape and run away. They sought refuge with some relatives who were living far away. And so that was the very same night that he was born. And he became teacher Pondwa, which means we will be murdered. For the Shauna, this way of choosing and giving names. In fact, their entire way of life was turned upside down starting in the late 19th century. The British diamond magnate Cecil John Rhodes, I'm going to pause for booing,
马巴萨说，就是他叔叔父母居住的同一个村庄。所以他们不得不逃跑。他们向住在远方的一些亲戚寻求庇护。就在那天晚上，他出生了。他成了Teacher Pondwa，意思是“我们将被谋杀”。对于绍纳人来说，这种选择和给予名字的方式，事实上，他们整个生活方式在19世纪末开始被颠覆。英国钻石大亨塞西尔·约翰·罗兹（我要停顿一下，让大家嘘声），
enters the story here. He played a major role in establishing South Africa's colonial government and began plotting to set up a similar colony to the north. This was the country which he brought under the British crown and formed into a British colony. Rhodes financed the British invasion of territory occupied by the Endevele and Schoenna people. Territory that Europeans nonetheless felt was theirs for the taking. Wild lands in the heart of Africa, which his vision pictured as the home of a thriving, prosperous people,
在这里进入了故事。他在建立南非殖民政府方面发挥了重要作用，并开始策划在北方建立一个类似的殖民地。这就是他置于英国王室统治下并形成英国殖民地的国家。罗兹资助了英国对恩德贝莱人和绍纳人居住领土的入侵。欧洲人却认为这些领土是他们可以占有的。非洲中心地带的荒地，他的愿景将其描绘成一个繁荣昌盛的人民的家园，
but populated at that time only by wild beasts and roving tribes. In 1895, after a brutal war, British settlers created a new colonial state named after Rhodes himself. Rhodes was established as a so-called settler colony, which is exactly what it sounds like. Large groups of British settlers took the land by force, establishing their own government and steamrolling over the Africans who live there. It was a total attempt at transforming a whole people. Innocent Monsindo is a Zimbabwean historian. It's an attempt to change people's identities, an attempt to force people to either hybridize or mimic particular ways of doing things,
但在当时只居住着野兽和流浪部落。1895年，经过一场残酷的战争，英国定居者建立了一个以罗兹本人命名的新殖民国家。罗兹被建立为一个所谓的定居者殖民地，这正是它听起来的样子。大批英国定居者武力夺取土地，建立了自己的政府，并碾压了居住在那里的非洲人。这是一场彻底改造整个民族的尝试。伊诺森特·蒙辛多是一位津巴布韦历史学家。这是一种改变人们身份的尝试，一种强迫人们要么杂交，要么模仿特定做事方式的尝试，
doing justice, ways of dressing, language. White Rhodesian seized the cattle of indigenous farmers, burned their crops, and locked Africans into a tax system that was tantamount to slavery. Whites got access to the best jobs, while Africans were forced into low-wage labor in mines or on farms. Under this new racial hierarchy, English became the language of power. Africans had to adapt.
伸张正义的方式、穿着方式、语言。白人罗得西亚人没收了土著农民的牛，烧毁了他们的庄稼，并将非洲人锁在了一个等同于奴隶制的税收系统中。白人获得了最好的工作机会，而非洲人则被迫在矿山或农场从事低薪劳动。在这种新的种族等级制度下，英语成为了权力的语言。非洲人不得不适应。
being able to speak it as an African granted you a little more access, perhaps the slightly higher position on the farm or on the factory floor. That meant that ancient traditions began to take a back seat to the more immediate realities of colonialism. Shana naming practices
作为一个非洲人能够说英语，让你获得了一点更多的机会，也许在农场或工厂车间里处于稍微高一点的位置。这意味着古老的传统开始让位于殖民主义更直接的现实。绍纳人的命名习俗
where parents gave names that told stories and were meant to shape their children's destinies, those were becoming less common. Ignatius Mabasa says at times people will find that their name was considered too difficult by the employer. So they were given another one.
父母给孩子起的名字讲述着故事，旨在塑造孩子的命运，这些变得不那么常见了。伊格内修斯·马巴萨说，有时人们会发现他们的名字被雇主认为太难了。所以他们被给了另一个名字。
So, you know, my name is Tirivangani. Oh, that's too long. That's too long. Can I call you, Peter? So you have a period, probably say, from the 1920s going up. Most of the names that you have among indigenous people are names that are being derived from the association with the white population. You know, so I'm working with Mr. Brown. I'll go and give Mr. Brown's name to my son.
所以，你知道，我的名字是Tirivangani。哦，那太长了。那太长了。我可以叫你彼得吗？所以你有一个时期，大概是从1920年代开始。土著人民中拥有的大多数名字都是从与白人人口的联系中衍生出来的名字。你知道，所以我正在和布朗先生一起工作。我会去把布朗先生的名字给我儿子。
If Mr. Brown has children, I'll also give names of Mr. Brown to my children. One of the driving forces and the replacement of Shauna Names with English ones was the church. Christian missionaries descended on the region, setting up churches, hospitals, and schools all over the colony. Some of those missionaries encouraged Ignatius Mabas's grandmother to come to school. Eventually she was baptized, and with that came a name change. My grandmother, Masuraga, became Emma, and her brother, Simbara-kutaya, baptized John. Magyrega, or Emma, would eventually give birth to his son who was baptized and called Augustine. He in turn had a son named Ignatius.
如果布朗先生有孩子，我也会把布朗先生的名字给我的孩子。用英文名字取代绍纳名字的驱动力之一是教会。基督教传教士来到该地区，在整个殖民地建立教堂、医院和学校。其中一些传教士鼓励伊格内修斯·马巴萨的祖母来上学。最终她受洗了，随之而来的是名字的改变。我的祖母Masuraga变成了艾玛，她的兄弟Simbara-kutaya受洗为约翰。Magyrega，或者说艾玛，最终生下了他的儿子，他受洗并被命名为奥古斯丁。他反过来有一个儿子叫伊格内修斯。
Similar naming choices were being made at the exact same time by Africans throughout the colony. Shona names did not disappear, but, but they were mostly just used at home. In public, at school or at work, English names dominated. For the first half of British rule in Rhodesia, Africans did this dance, choosing Western names in order to navigate the colonial system. But starting in the 1960s,
在同一时间，整个殖民地的非洲人也在做出类似的命名选择。绍纳名字并没有消失，但它们大多只在家里使用。在公共场合、学校或工作中，英文名字占主导地位。在英国统治罗得西亚的前半段，非洲人跳着这种舞，选择西方名字以在殖民体系中航行。但从1960年代开始，
the country would experience enormous political upheaval. After a rebellion, and then a revolution, back to back, it emerged a different nation with a very different set of names. Africans would begin turning back to Shona and other indigenous languages and choosing names that were charged with political resistance. This pushback started when white settlers staged their own resistance by deciding that Rhodesia would no longer be a British colony. The people of Rhodesia will not be hindered in our determination to continue exercising
这个国家将经历巨大的政治动荡。在一次叛乱，然后是一场革命，接连发生之后，它出现了一个不同的国家，有着一套非常不同的名字。非洲人将开始回归绍纳语和其他本土语言，并选择充满政治抵抗的名字。这种反击始于白人定居者通过决定罗得西亚不再是英国殖民地来策划他们自己的抵抗。罗得西亚人民在继续行使我们确定无疑的权利以示威的决心上，不会受到阻碍。
our undoubted right to demonstrate. Led by Prime Minister Ian Smith, Rhodesia declared its independence from Great Britain in 1965. We do, by this proclamation, give to the people of Rhodesia, the Constitution annexed here too. God save the Queen. White settlers in Rhodesia had invented their own identity, calling themselves Rhodes. And they were living a very comfortable life. They had good jobs, houses with swimming pools, staff to keep it all running, plus excellent weather.
在伊恩·史密斯总理的领导下，罗得西亚于1965年宣布脱离英国独立。我们通过这份公告，将附带的宪法赋予罗得西亚人民。上帝保佑女王。罗得西亚的白人定居者发明了自己的身份，称自己为罗得西亚人。他们过着非常舒适的生活。他们有好的工作、带游泳池的房子、维持这一切运转的工作人员，加上极好的天气。
Thanks to an aggressive come-to-Rodisia ad campaign that Becca to white people in Europe and the US, the settler population swelled to about 273,000. But this was a tiny minority compared to the roughly 6 million black Africans in Rhodesia, many of whom had been forced off their land by the settlers. Those Africans had hoped to participate in Rhodesia's government. But when the colony declared itself independent,
多亏了一场积极的“来罗得西亚”广告活动，吸引了欧洲和美国的白人，定居者人口增加到约273,000人。但这与罗得西亚约600万黑人非洲人相比只是极少数，其中许多人被定居者赶出了土地。那些非洲人曾希望参与罗得西亚的政府。但当殖民地宣布独立时，
it became clear that this new nation would be run exclusively by the white settlers. For the Africans, this was the last straw. They began to suddenly have their eyes open. Wow. Oh, so we are oppressed. Oh, so we also have a culture. We have a language. We have a right to be. Oh, this is actually our land.
很明显，这个新国家将完全由白人定居者管理。对于非洲人来说，这是最后一根稻草。他们开始突然睁开眼睛。哇。哦，原来我们被压迫了。哦，原来我们也有文化。我们有一种语言。我们有生存的权利。哦，这实际上是我们的土地。
They were witnessing this massive wave of independence movements sweeping across the continent in the mid-60s. Inspired and emboldened, Africans in Rhodesia turned from assimilation to full-scale open rebellion, everything from attacks against the state launched by insurgent and nationalist groups, to the symbolic shedding of European names and returning to African ones. They start giving names that address or speak to this situation of being oppressed. People were choosing assertive statement-making shone name. leading the charge were nationalist leaders
他们目睹了60年代中期席卷整个非洲大陆的独立运动浪潮。受到鼓舞和壮胆，罗得西亚的非洲人从同化转向了全面公开的叛乱，从叛乱和民族主义团体发起的针对国家的袭击，到象征性地抛弃欧洲名字并回归非洲名字。他们开始起那些针对或谈论这种被压迫状况的名字。人们正在选择果断的、声明式的绍纳名字。带头的是民族主义领导人，
who took on names like Teorairoba, which means to spill blood, and Chibwe Chiteza, which is hard to translate, but basically suggests someone who cannot be moved. Ignatius says one of his uncles was given a name that reflected this growing sense of defiance. His full name was
他们采用了像Teorairoba这样的名字，意思是“流血”，以及Chibwe Chiteza，这很难翻译，但基本上暗示了一个不可动摇的人。伊格内修斯说，他的一位叔叔被起了一个反映这种日益增长的蔑视感的名字。他的全名是
Tichava Tonga Mabunu. We will eventually rule over the whites. What a name? Coming up, Zimbabwe wins its independence. And with that, the nation's culture of big, bold names, really takes off. That's after the break. After 15 years of war with the white Rhodesian government, Africans finally won their independence in 1980.
Tichava Tonga Mabunu。我们最终将统治白人。多么名字啊！接下来，津巴布韦赢得了独立。随之而来的是，这个国家宏大、大胆的名字文化真正起飞了。休息之后再谈。在与白人罗得西亚政府进行了15年的战争后，非洲人终于在1980年赢得了独立。
They renamed their country, Zimbabwe. Zimbabwe was one of the last former colonies to win independence. After watching its neighbors struggle to figure out what to do with their colonial legacies, Zimbabwe's new government decided the best approach was to go very slowly. And this spirit of gradualism would even inspire a shift in Zimbabwe's naming culture. The new prime minister was a man named Robert Gabriel Mugabe. There is a lot to say about him and his complicated legacy. But the Mugabe of 1980 embodied the moment.
他们将国家更名为津巴布韦。津巴布韦是最后一批赢得独立的殖民地之一。在看着邻国努力弄清楚如何处理殖民遗产后，津巴布韦新政府决定最好的方法是慢慢来。这种渐进主义的精神甚至激发了津巴布韦命名文化的转变。新总理是一个名叫罗伯特·加布里埃尔·穆加贝的人。关于他和他复杂的遗产有很多话要说。但1980年的穆加贝体现了那个时刻。
He was a revolutionary leader and an icon of anti-colonial resistance. But he also was a missionary-educated man who spoke crisp English and was known for his love of cricket and impeccably tailored Savile row suits. There is that saying that Mugabe was more English than the British. This is historian, innocent Mucindo. The political leadership of the time was more English than the English. As Prime Minister, Mugabe encouraged gradualism. There was land redistribution, but it was small. scale. New schools were built, but many of them continued to mirror the British system.
他是一位革命领袖和反殖民抵抗的偶像。但他也是一位受过传教士教育的人，说着地道的英语，以热爱板球和剪裁完美的萨维尔街西装而闻名。有句谚语说穆加贝比英国人更像英国人。这是历史学家伊诺森特·穆辛多。当时的政治领导层比英国人更像英国人。作为总理，穆加贝鼓励渐进主义。有土地再分配，但规模很小。建立了新学校，但其中许多继续模仿英国体系。
Other colonial flourishes remained too. African judges insisted on wearing powdered horsehair wigs, and English held firm as the official language in education, government, and just about every other part of civic life in Zimbabwe. But as the country was figuring out its new identity, what to keep and what to shed, one of the main places where Zimbabians could really experiment and push boundaries was names. We're talking of a free Zimbabwe. Give Moshonai as a Zimbabwean academic. So we're also free to do whatever we want with the language
其他殖民色彩也保留了下来。非洲法官坚持戴粉末状的马毛假发，英语在津巴布韦的教育、政府和几乎所有其他公民生活领域中保持着官方语言的地位。但当这个国家正在弄清楚它的新身份，什么该保留，什么该抛弃时，津巴布韦人真正可以实验和突破界限的主要领域之一就是名字。我们谈论的是一个自由的津巴布韦。吉夫·莫肖奈是一位津巴布韦学者。所以我们也自由地对语言做任何我们想做的事，
as long as it satisfies what we want to do with the names. We can break the rules. We are not free. After nearly a century of repression of being told what you could or could not do, it was in this new free Zimbabwe. that the culture of wild experimentation and play with names really took off. As power shifted into the hands of Zimbabians,
只要它满足我们想用名字做的事情。我们可以打破规则。我们不自由。在近一个世纪的压迫，被告知你能做什么或不能做什么之后，正是在这个新的自由津巴布韦，狂野的实验和玩弄名字的文化真正起飞了。随着权力转移到津巴布韦人手中，
so did they sense that they were able to do whatever they wanted with English. Yes, it was still the dominant language, but now Africans were in control, free to remix and shonify their names as they liked. I would not just pick a name like obey, like together, like polite, that's too easy. Now we can add a verb, a determiner, an adjective and compound and come up with a name. Now I can go and even express myself more and say, God knows more blessing or glad more or worse more,
他们也感觉到他们可以对英语做任何他们想做的事。是的，它仍然是主导语言，但现在非洲人掌握了控制权，可以自由地按照自己的喜好重新混合和“绍纳化”他们的名字。我不会只选一个像“服从”（Obey）、“一起”（Together）、“礼貌”（Polite）这样的名字，那太简单了。现在我们可以加一个动词、一个限定词、一个形容词并复合，想出一个名字。现在我可以去表达更多，说“上帝知道”（God knows）、“更多祝福”（More blessing）或“更快乐”（Glad more）或“更糟”（Worse more），
playing around with English and making it even more complicated. This meant that a name like Hajinei, which conveys a message of acceptance and resilience in Shona, got translated to No Matter. They were also taken names inspired by the Bible, like grace and faith and mercy, and translating them into Shona, which was new. These words were never used as names in Shana before. My younger brother's name is Kuziva Kwashe, which is a popular Shona name. After independence, you started to see more of its English translation, which is God knows.
玩弄英语，使它变得更加复杂。这意味着像Hajinei这样的名字，在绍纳语中传达了接受和韧性的信息，被翻译成了“没关系”（No Matter）。他们还采用了受圣经启发的名字，如“恩典”（Grace）、“信仰”（Faith）和“怜悯”（Mercy），并将它们翻译成绍纳语，这是新的。这些词以前从未在绍纳语中用作名字。我弟弟的名字是Kuziva Kwashe，这是一个流行的绍纳名字。独立后，你开始看到更多它的英文翻译，即“上帝知道”（God knows）。
I would bet that most Zimbabians know of at least one. God knows. It's been 45 years since independence, and these names are everywhere. There's a famous ex-footballer Haveluk Dube, and a politician named Welshman Moube. A friend in Harare once had to call the police, and the officer who showed up introduced himself as Inspector Breakfast. We weren't sure if his first name was Breakfast or Inspector. When I was researching the story, I came across one of several.
我敢打赌，大多数津巴布韦人都知道至少一个“上帝知道”。距离独立已经45年了，这些名字随处可见。有一位著名的前足球运动员哈维卢克·杜贝，还有一位名叫威尔士人·穆贝的政治家。哈拉雷的一位朋友曾经不得不报警，出现的警官介绍自己为“早餐督察”（Inspector Breakfast）。我们不确定他的名字是“早餐”还是“督察”。当我研究这个故事时，我偶然发现了几个
online forums, posing the question, what is the strangest Zimbabwean name you've heard? There were all sorts of submissions, names like Hard Life and Lieutenant, most of which I could hazard a guess to their backstory. But there was one name on there that I was especially curious about. Please could you stop by introducing yourself? Tell us who you are. My name is More Precision Muzadzi. More Precision Mazzazi is a politician based in Zimbabwe's capital, Harare. His name is a His name is a knot to the work his father did for decades. My father worked for British American tobacco for almost 30 years.
在线论坛，提出了这个问题：你听过的最奇怪的津巴布韦名字是什么？有各种各样的提交，像“艰难生活”（Hard Life）和“中尉”（Lieutenant）这样的名字，其中大多数我可以猜测它们的背景故事。但上面有一个名字我特别好奇。请你先自我介绍一下好吗？告诉我们你是谁。我的名字是More Precision Muzadzi。More Precision Mazzazi是一位常驻津巴布韦首都哈拉雷的政治家。他的名字是他父亲几十年来所做工作的缩影。我父亲在英美烟草公司工作了近30年。
He was working as a machine operator. So in that department, there was a lot of equipment, which was manufactured by precision engineering. So that's where he got the idea of naming me. The fact that his name was in this online forum, full of Zimbabweans, suggests that it's seen as unusual, even by our own creative naming standards. name is something that I really love and adore, and I cherish and I treasured. Everywhere I go. People actually are curious to say, what's your name again? My name has got meaning, slowly meaningless name. It means being accurate to the point in whatever I do. So it's kind of inspires me to do the right thing. In the last two decades, Zimbabwe's economy has been in collapse.
他是一名机器操作员。所以在这个部门，有很多设备是由精密工程制造的。所以这就是他给我起名的灵感来源。他的名字出现在这个充满津巴布韦人的在线论坛上的事实，表明即使按照我们自己的创造性命名标准，它也被认为是不同寻常的。这个名字是我真正热爱和崇拜的，我珍惜并珍视它。无论我走到哪里，人们实际上都很好奇，说，你叫什么名字来着？我的名字有含义，不是毫无意义的名字。它意味着在我所做的任何事情中都要准确。所以它激励我做正确的事。在过去的二十年里，津巴布韦的经济一直处于崩溃状态。
Record-breaking inflation forced millions to leave and fan out across the globe. This means that the the world has had a lot more exposure to Zimbabwe's unique naming conventions. These unique names have also gotten much more attention outside of Zimbabwe. Thanks to social media, especially TikTok, where they are a popular punchline. Which African countries have the weirdest names? Zimbabwe. I know someone whose name is gearbox. Gearbox.
创纪录的通货膨胀迫使数百万人离开并散布到全球各地。这意味着世界对津巴布韦独特的命名惯例有了更多的接触。这些独特的名字在津巴布韦以外也受到了更多的关注。多亏了社交媒体，尤其是TikTok，它们在那里是一个流行的笑话梗。“哪个非洲国家的名字最奇怪？”“津巴布韦。”“我认识一个人叫‘变速箱’（Gearbox）。变速箱。”
Let me tell you what they do in Zimbabwe. I met someone called Anything. Anything. Anything. This is all mostly in good fun, but Tanaka Chedora worries that the social media roasts, plus the mass exodus out of Zimbabwe, could one day spell the end of a unique naming culture. We are now aware, for example, of what the world out there thinks of us because of our names, right? And to tell you the truth, most is my parents now, when they have children,
让我告诉你他们在津巴布韦做什么。我遇到了一个叫“任何东西”（Anything）的人。任何东西。任何东西。这大多是为了好玩，但塔纳卡·切多拉担心社交媒体的嘲讽，加上津巴布韦的大规模外流，有一天可能会终结一种独特的命名文化。例如，我们现在意识到外面的世界因为我们的名字而怎么看我们，对吧？说实话，大多数津巴布韦父母现在在生孩子时，
they are also thinking of where the children will go when they grow up. Tanaka says he's seeing parents opting for names like Jaden, Jordan and Caden. The kinds of names inspired more by reality TV stars and Premier League footballers than by the New Testament. Most of Zimbabweans have now, what we can call an outward orientation. They are saying when my children go and live outside Zimbabwe, I want them to carry a name that does not bring laughter. For a long time, I really didn't like the name Learn More. Zimbabwe and stand-up comedian Learn More Janasi started to have reservations about his name when he found out the story behind it.
他们也在考虑孩子们长大后会去哪里。塔纳卡说，他看到父母选择像杰登（Jaden）、乔丹（Jordan）和凯登（Caden）这样的名字。这些名字更多地受到真人秀明星和英超足球运动员的启发，而不是新约圣经。大多数津巴布韦人现在有一种我们可以称之为“向外导向”的心态。他们说，当我的孩子去津巴布韦以外的地方生活时，我希望他们带一个不会带来嘲笑的名字。很长一段时间里，我真的不喜欢“多学习”（Learn More）这个名字。津巴布韦单口喜剧演员莱恩摩尔·贾纳西在发现名字背后的故事后，开始对他的名字有所保留。
It's because my mother was young when she heard me. So my name was a message to my mother. To always remind her to learn more from what she had done, you know? So for like a week, actually, my name was realized. They actually named me Realize. and then they realized, no, no, that's too much. Two on the nose. Let's name him, Learn More.
这是因为我母亲生我时还很年轻。所以我的名字是给我母亲的一个信息。时刻提醒她从她所做的事情中学习更多，你知道吗？所以大约一周的时间，实际上，我的名字是“意识到”（Realize）。然后他们意识到，不，不，那太过了。太直白了。让我们叫他“多学习”。
When Learn More first started performing around the world, he used the stage name Long John the comedian. But privately, when he'd share his real name, people were eager to hear about its origins. Learn More is a Zimbabwean story. So that's when I went back to my actual name, instead of a stage name. And then I started calling myself Learn More. And it's a conversation starter. As soon as I introduce myself,
当“多学习”第一次开始在世界各地表演时，他使用了艺名“长约翰喜剧演员”（Long John the comedian）。但私下里，当他分享他的真名时，人们渴望了解它的起源。“多学习”是一个津巴布韦故事。所以那时我回到了我的真名，而不是艺名。然后我开始称自己为“多学习”。这是一个谈话的开场白。当我介绍自己时，
everybody wants to know why. And that's my way to start educating people, you know. But Loemort says we shouldn't be shying away from names like his, which are hard won and tightly stitched into the fabric of who we are as a country. Our names are very unique. And they come from a real place. So honestly, like, if you have a name like that, you know, if you come from Zimbabwe, just be proud of it.
每个人都想知道为什么。这是我开始教育人们的方式，你知道吗。但莱恩摩尔说，我们不应该回避像他这样的名字，这些名字是来之不易的，并紧紧地缝合在我们作为一个国家的结构中。我们的名字非常独特。它们来自一个真实的地方。所以老实说，如果你有这样一个名字，你知道，如果你来自津巴布韦，就为它感到骄傲。
You know, because it's a story. You know, we are all unique. We are a very unique little country, and we should be proud of it. And I am. My relationship to these names has shifted over the years. For a long time, they felt foreign, not really ours. But as I've come to understand them better, I can appreciate the history that led us to them, the Zimbabweanness of them.
你知道，因为它是一个故事。你知道，我们都是独特的。我们是一个非常独特的小国家，我们应该为它感到骄傲。我也是。我对这些名字的关系多年来发生了变化。很长一段时间里，它们感觉很陌生，不是我们自己的。但随着我更好地理解它们，我可以欣赏导致我们拥有它们的历史，它们的“津巴布韦性”。
When it came to naming my child, I wanted to be a very child. one that did what our names have done for generations, whether in Shona, Devele or Zimbabwe in English. I wanted a name that told a story. Every year in Zimbabwe, you have a long, dry season. And when it finally rains, everything changes. The landscape is green and lush. It's completely transformed. My son came after a long wait. His name is Yanaya. which Enshana means the rain has come. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kim Chaganetsa and edited by Christopher Johnson. This episode was mixed by Martine Gonzalez with music by Swan Real and George Langford.
当给我的孩子起名时，我想要一个非常津巴布韦的名字。一个像我们几代人的名字一样，无论是在绍纳语、恩德贝莱语还是津巴布韦英语中，都做着同样事情的名字。我想要一个讲述故事的名字。在津巴布韦，每年都有一个漫长的旱季。当它终于下雨时，一切都变了。景观变得绿色而郁郁葱葱。它完全改变了。我的儿子在漫长的等待后出生。他的名字是Yanaya，在绍纳语中意思是“雨来了”。《99% Invisible》本周由金·查加内萨制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊编辑。本集由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。
Fact-checking by Nydia Battista. Special thanks this week to Trust Semende and Adam Hutchings. Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Kirk Colstady, the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Lachamadonne, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of the visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
事实核查由尼迪亚·巴蒂斯塔完成。本周特别感谢特鲁斯特·塞门德和亚当·哈钦斯。凯西·2是我们的执行制片人，柯克·科尔斯塔迪是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、拉查马多内、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。
In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. dot org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。